it's time for roses and Rosie hi you
guys it's me Lord
Lima and I miss you so much we're back
we're back do it take a theatrical to
return to the couch I'm so exhausted and
excited at the same time you know what
that means have a glass of wine it'll
calm me down and keep your good feels
going mother's milk it's the medicine we
all need please drink responsibly
oh how are you guys it's been a minute
it's been a couple of months but we are
back and for good reason why am I tired
because on Monday night I was at Dancing
with the Stars with our girl Hannah B
when in the Mirrorball everybody kind of
grats she believed she could so she did
love it cheers to Hannah but of course
we don't recap Dancing with the Stars
here on roses and Rose a we do The
Bachelor franchise and what did we get
during V Dancing with the Stars season
finale the premiere of Peter Webber's
first trailer for his season of The
Bachelor I know my god my plane crashed
and I'm deaf does that take more bit of
a joke anyway deep breath I am here to
review the new trailer Peter season of
course returns to ABC and January ah as
I can't wait also want to announce that
we will now be doing an episode of roses
in Rose a every Tuesday per usual until
that premiere camera in the dog
a guzzle and we're going to play a brand
anew roses and rose a game with some of
your favorite bachelor nation alumni
it's called zip or spill where they must
choose I asked them a question will they
take a sip of their drink and not answer
or will they spill the tea you know I'm
saying we're gonna have some really fun
guests a flat okay I have no idea what's
coming but I know that my life will
never be the same
let's just begin with a big old cheers
to this a minute and a half of
deliciousness dude the trailer make you
guys excited for Peter season don't
drink every time he was already
shirtless
we begin with some very cinematic epic
sexual top gun nods we've got the
sunsets we've got Peter in the pilot
seat we've got those sunglasses is it
Tom Cruise or Peter Webber it's Peter
Rabbit definitely Peter the epic music
plays as the journey that promises to be
unforgettable begins also Peters got
some epic stubble going on now and I'm
glad like Copan Underwood eat a bit of a
baby face and I think that the beard
helps they just up a little bit you know
you don't want to look damn it it's
Chris Harris how does he know you don't
want to look 12 you know stop calling
I'm busy one time I called them and he
was like you just interrupted it was
amazing I was just watching rose and
Rosie
he's so cute it's a supportive get you a
man as the birthday or a man it flies
you around in his plane clearly we are
going to get a lot of pilot moments as
expected cheers for every time pilot
Pete was in the pilot seat in the pilot
seat or washing the plane and Peter's
been working out this is me imitating
him with the hose this is me imitating
him with the hose I was he washing a
plane in jeans for television of course
we knew Peter from the windmill
everybody but I think we're gonna go
from the windmill to the mile-high club
real fast because this season looks sexy
don't drink for every sexy hookup moment
I'm not sitting there watching it like
Peter I think pilot B it's gonna be good
he's really nice you guys I've
interviewed him that interview will be
up soon detail line.com before the play
so nice guy miss family suck it nice and
shirtless it also looks like we have
some gorgeous women competing for pilot
Pete's heart this season just some
stunning ladies cheers to them and then
of course
there's still something there what
started a lot of conversation during
Dancing with the Stars one significant
woman Hannah Brown is back everybody
look I know everybody gets so riled up
about when people from the past come on
to the new season leave your comments
below please I want to know what you
think but that is the way the show works
you guys it's a cyclical nature of a
show and it kind of has to be otherwise
how would we justify people getting over
other people so quickly Colton Underwood
went right from Becca kufran season to
bachelor in paradise and we watched him
cry and move on from her and then he was
the bachelor you know and Becca came to
paradise Hannah Brown came to paradise
like it just keeps going you know so it
keeps going and they keep showing up and
Hannah has said in several interviews
that she doesn't want to talk about her
love life as much anymore which I
totally get but she appears to still be
having some fields for the Peter Webber
what really happens though look I think
they're trying to give us a little
trickery they show us a sweeping shot of
a mysterious City so when and where does
Hannah Brown show up as Hannah told me
when I interviewed her after she won
Dancing with the Stars Monday night she
was filming Dancing with the Stars all
season I know Peter asks her to come
back to the mansion but she literally
would not have had time to film both
shows so she doesn't rejoin the season I
don't think it seems impossible then
again in the bachelor world is anything
impossible
you know
[Music]
I'm very well that was a good song for
his first little promo I loved it
okay everybody those are my thoughts I
simply cannot wait for Peter Weber
season of The Bachelor I think it's
gonna be amazing
tell me your thoughts let me know in the
comments below
what you expect what you want to see
what kind of lady
you want for pilot Pete I love you all
so much again roses and Rose a is going
to be here every Tuesday until the
bachelor premiere with fun new episodes
our new game sipper spill with Bachelor
alumni who you love and then when the
new season returns of course we will
review every Tuesday as per huge thank
you guys so much for watching especially
to all of those who have been watching
for all the seasons that we've been
doing roses and Rosie please tell your
friends about it say hey guys
significant time to jump in and check
out roses and Rosie and I know that I
spoke to you guys about how I was going
to launch a podcast I did need a little
break in between all of the bachelor
coverage I also started kind of a new
job here at et so I've been busy and I
really wanted to do it right it will
launch in the new year I love you guys
so much thank you for watching let's
finish this off strong
[Music]
oh and guys of course a quick vlog JC is
back to don't worry he's not going
anywhere and he's feeling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]